لكن مشاهدينا السؤال الان بعد هذا القرار
قرار الجنائيه الدوليه باعتقال بوتين ما
مدى امكانيه تطبيق هذا القرار وما هي
العقبات التي قد تقف امام تنفيذه فعليا
القرار سيصعب السفر على بوتين لكن المحكمه
ليس لديها شرطه خاصه بها لتنفيذ اوامرها
بعد بل تعتمد كليا على تعاون الدول
الاعضاء في المحكمه الجنائيه والبالغ
عددها 123 دوله الذي يتعين عليها تنفيذ
مذكرتي التوقيف بحقهم اما بالنسبه للعقبات
الرئيسيه التي يمكن ان يواجهها قرار
المحكمه هو ان روسيا كالولايات المتحده
وايضا الصين ليست عضوا في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه والمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تمكنت من توجيه اتهامات الى بوتين
لان اوكرانيا قبلت صلاحيتها بشان الوضع
الحالي علما ان كيف ليست عضوا ايضا فيها
في المقابل موسكو رفضت مذكرات التوقيف ضد
بشكل قاطع واكدت انها لا روسيا تسلم
مواطنيها تحت اي ظروف معتبره قرارات
المحكمه باطله وفي هذا الاطار اوضح
مراقبون انه من غير المرجح ان ينتهي
المطاف ببوتين في قفص الاتهام بسبب جرائم
حرب ما لم يتغير النظام في روسيا وللعمه
ايضا بوتين ليس الرئيس الوحيد الذي اصدرت
بحقه قرارات اعتقال فالتاريخ شاهد على
محاكمه العديد من القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب مثل
سلوبتان الرئيس اليوجسلافي السابق
وتشيلسيلي الرئيس ليبيريا السابق وفيما
يخص وجود خيارات اخرى لدى المحكمه بهذا
الصدد فالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لا
تستطيع محاكمه المشتبه بهم غيابيا لكن
المدعي العام لدى المحكمه كريم خان اوضح
ان المحكمه لديها وسائل اخرى للمضي قدما
ببعض القضايا كعقد جلسه استماع لتاكيد
التهم الموجهه